people of different walks of life would
be using silk road to primarily what was
the Prime primary thing drugs it was
primarily drugs and that's where it
started it started off with Ross
Albrecht growing mushrooms out in the
wilderness of California and selling
them but really his was more of a
Libertarian Viewpoint I mean it was like
you choose what you want to do for
yourself and do it and in the way Silk
Road kind of had the anonymity is it
used what's called Tor the onion router
which is an anonymizing uh function on
uh on the Deep Web it was actually
invented by the U.S Navy uh back in the
mid 90s or so but it also used
cryptocurrency so it was the first time
like we saw this birth on the internet
uh mixing cryptocurrency uh and uh an IP
blocking software so you know in cyber
crime you go after one the IP address
and trace it through the network or two
you go after the cash and this one kind
of blocked both cash meaning the flow of
money physical or digital and then
um IP is the some kind of identifying
thing of the computer it's your
telephone number for on your computer so
yeah all computers have you know a
unique uh for octet uh numbers you know
it's a
123.123.123.123 and you know the
computer uses DNS or domain name
services to to render that name so if
you're looking for you know CNN.com your
computer then translates that to that IP
address or that telephone number where
it can find that information didn't sell
code used to have guns in the beginning
or it or was that considered to have
guns or was did it naturally emerge and
then Ross realized like this is not good
it went back and forth uh I think there
were guns on there and he tried to
police it
um you know he uh he told himself the
the captain of the boat so he had to
follow his rules so you know I think you
took off those posts eventually and
moved guns elsewhere what was the system
of censorship that he used obviously
selecting what is okay and not okay I
mean it's alone he's the captain of the
boat do you know by chance if there was
uh a lot of debates and criticisms
internally amongst the criminals of what
is and isn't allowed I mean it's
interesting to see a totally different
moral code emerge that's outside the
legal code of society we did get the the
server and was able to read all of the
chat logs that what that happened I mean
all the records were there
um I don't remember big debates I mean
there was a clear leadership yeah and
that was the final decision that was the
the CEO of Silk Road and so primarily
was drugs and primarily out of an
ideology of Freedom which is uh if you
want to use drugs you should be able to
use drugs you should put in your body
what you want to put in your body